what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the first in a four-part
series called the resurrection of
Magneto and this comic is going to blow
your mind so the first thing this does
is this picks up with storm basically
having a dream where she's almost kind
of mentally reached out to by Magneto or
at the very least sees him in the sense
that he's just kind of standing on the
shore right with this lava and all this
kind of stuff and says auror I was wrong
now first things first this is not the
far Shore for those of you guys who are
curious if you don't know what the far
Shore is it's basically the last stop
for any and all Cosmic entities that
exist out there that is not the role of
Magneto here instead Magneto has
basically perished right he's dead now
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with that he died during
Judgment Day in probably one of the most
dope moments ever in the history of the
comics where his heart gets ripped out
and he's just using his control over
electromagnetism to like keep the blood
pumping through his body he lasts just
long enough to continue the fight and
then dies it was amazing right Judgment
day it is in the X-Men playlist make
sure you guys check that out at the end
of the video The Avengers versus the
X-Men versus the eternals uh the
eternals get wrecked by the way which
makes sense cuz they suck so here's the
thing right storm and realizing that
Magneto is reaching out to her is in
effect in some capacity saying that he's
not necessarily alive but he can be
retrieved and the reason why this is so
important is that in Marvel Comics death
is not an absolute right and a lot of
people kind of know this right you know
like characters come back from the de
all the time true right but like when
you actually get into the nitty-gritty
of it you can travel to the afterlife
retrieve the soul of a person and bring
them back it's been done before so it's
not an uncommon thing to take place well
it is kind of uncommon for it to play
out that way but the fact is that it can
be done the reality here is precious few
people actually know how to do this
doctor strange is dealing with
everything going on in Gods right now
right like the return of Oblivion the
Skinner boxes which is ridiculously
amazing concept right like there's a
whole bunch of stuff going on there's
precious few people she can reach out to
but there's one individual in the
entirety of the Marvel universe that had
previously given her the ability to
transition from one dimension to another
and that person ladies and gentlemen is
Adam Brasher so she leaves and she goes
to visit the blue Marvel now I told you
guys there was no direct indication that
Enigma as he was presented in Defenders
Beyond and like the Dominion that we see
in the X-Men Comics that they're
connected but all of it seems like it is
because the writer of this comic aling
and Kieran Gillan the guy who's working
on the X-Men Comics right now they were
close at hand so when Storm shows up
here you immediately have Adam Basher
talking to tiia the mother of Galactus
from a different from a previous
Universe there's a whole story behind it
we can cover it if you're interested but
basically they're talking about the
nature of of enigma the being they
encountered that was originally
introduced in Defenders Beyond as being
more powerful than the one above all
it's all tied together right the fact
that it's all kind of crossing over here
shows it's the exact same being they're
hunting for the same person they just
don't realize they're hunting for the
same person right the X-Men and the
Defenders now of course tyia immediately
freaks out because she thinks that
Storm's here to attack her and Adam
Basher is like no no no no it's cool
she's a friend it's all cop pathetic and
so what storm does is she explains
everything going on to Adam vasher that
Magneto had previously died that she's
looking to bring Magneto back because
his power is necessary but his role is
necessary let me tell you something man
Magneto in recent years I love Magneto
during house and powers of X don't get
me wrong his his time during X-Men it's
been dope and there's been some amazing
like just amazing moments right when he
tells those people during House of X you
have new Gods now I mean just stuff like
that right there's been some dope
moments with Magneto in recent years but
old school Magneto from like back in the
80s man that guy guy would do whatever
it took there was an alternate reality
story where he eradicated all life on
Earth with an EMP because it was the
only way to win I mean dude this guy
Magneto let some I can't wait I'm sorry
I'm so excited people but it is an
exciting time in the X-Men Comics I
can't wait for Magneto to come back dude
I'm so hyped so what ends up happening
is that the kind of portals created
right now the nature of this portal is
that it's going to send storm down the
same path that Magneto went in effect
she's going to B basically transition to
the afterlife but what ends up happening
here is she jumps through the portal
before the readings can be verified by
Adam Basher now a lot of this is just
tied into the fact that Storm's like I'm
not waiting right and she just kind of
leaps in Adam Basher being a scientist
right being as powerful as he is he's
all about readings right all about
making sure that everything's balanced
and that kind of stuff and she even kind
of says like I'm standing at the edge of
a rooftop below me is a vast ocean I
have been here before there is no safety
only the leap right she just leaps into
the portal right just doesn't even ask
any questions just jumps straight in and
when she gets through she arrives at a
way station right basically the waiting
room as it's effectively called and what
you have here are these paths that are
basically represented by Cosmic entities
The Living Tribunal and mistress death
and so on and so forth the wheel right
as it was established and introduced in
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers run but waiting for her
specifically is Tarn the uncaring now
here's the thing right turnar the
uncaring for those of you guys who never
saw our videos on the sword event right
Tarn the uncaring which that's also in
the X-Men you guys really need to to
check out the X-Men playlist if you have
not done it yet because so much amazing
stuff happens Tarn the uncaring is a
mutant that has the ability to control
DNA the long and short of this is he can
shut your powers off he can turn your
powers back on he can give you new power
Powers he can change your powers he can
do all kinds of stuff right like this
this guy Magneto killed him by crushing
his head it was like it was like it was
like this fight that happened so fast
Magneto took his helmet off and like put
it on tarn's head and then crushed the
helmet with his powers and Tarn dude
Tarn died so fast he died faster than
blackbolt would if he fought anybody
meaningful if you can even believe that
right cuz blackbolt sucks he would die
almost immediately against anyone who
matters but the thing about this is that
Tarn kind of taunts storm a little bit
and he even kind of answers her
questions to a degree because this space
was created by the Scarlet Witch that's
one of the things to know she literally
created a space outside of all space and
time so that whenever mutants
specifically right mutants only whenever
they die they would go to this place as
a kind of waiting room of sorts and then
they would choose their path and then
they would move on to whatever that path
happened to be now was a little
mysterious right like do they choose
their path or is their path chosen for
them and there were a lot of questions
that were introduced that were just
never full ful fleshed out but the fact
remain Toren just kind of taunt her a
little bit it's like Magneto chose one
of these paths which one do you think it
is but it doesn't matter because like
I'm going to attack you now and destroy
you but when storm asked the question
like where are all the mutants who died
he's like I mean do you think they would
just be just crowded in this place you
think they would just hang out waiting
for you to show up to rescue them from
this fate right like no like they moved
on and they went and did their own thing
some of those mutants you will see again
and some of them you will never see
again right because they're just done
and gone and out of the picture but
Taran of course lashes out with the
intention of destroying storm because
when he asks her what are you looking
for her response is I'm looking to
resurrect Magneto which pisses him off
to no end because Magneto was the guy
who killed him and so of course he kind
of attacks her for a little bit but the
bigger point of this right it's not
really the fight between storm and tar
the uncaring because it is cool to see
and just like we would expect storm
absolutely dominates this guy what she
realizes is that when a person enters
this place the rules and laws of the
normal Universe do not apply which is to
say Tarn can only control his own DNA he
cannot do anything to storm and so storm
just overpowers this guy with a
quickness and then once the dust settles
and he's quote unquote destroyed if you
want to call it that she's met by asake
or aake I'm not really sure exactly how
you pronounce this let me know down in
the comments section for those of you
guys who are familiar with Egyptian
dialect and you know exactly how the
name is supposed to be pronounced
because she is of Egyptian Heritage and
in fact she is the ancestor of storm now
an important thing to understand here
right between I want to say it was
Gambit volume 1 the original miniseries
issues 2 and three and then New Mutants
volume one issue 32 I think this
answered the question of why it was that
storms seemed to have latent magic
potential because she always kind of had
that ability but it was never fully
fleshed out and the fact is that like
her ancestor is a direct servant of
ashor one of the Elder gods that existed
on Earth and was granted the ability to
manipulate Magic and so that ability to
control magic was kind of passed down
the generations to storm herself now it
doesn't mean that storm is on par with
someone like Steven strange or something
like that but it was always just kind of
like a the undercurrent of her character
that was never really overly explored
but was always kind of there and would
like crop up occasionally right so the
thing is like as they meet each other
and as they talk that this woman
provides a Little More Concept here
right a little more explanation here but
it's still very cloaken dagger because
she asked the question she says tell me
why you came here the response is Storm
it feels foolish to tell her that I
threw myself into the unknown on the
strength of a dream so one of the things
to know is that storm thinks that to
herself but her mind is basically being
read here so the response here is dreams
are vital little Aurora they are
messages from Gods even sometimes from
eternity the great all and carry meaning
Beyond meaning dreams are binding the
response to storm I dreamed of Max Ma
Magneto he was standing on a strange
Shore readying himself to enter a ruined
City his face turned away but in torment
it was more than a dream it was a
distress call right the response that
she gets here is yes but detail is
important we are in the place where
magic lives symbols and metaphors all
are the true reality anything you can
recall May point that way I.E that could
be any number of locations right we need
more details so we know where he went to
right like it's it's like as it's like
saying I I had a dream of a guy who was
standing on a beach okay cool well on
this beach right as you look around did
you happen to see like a sign that said
Venice Beach because now we know what
beach he's at so we can just go there
right that's basically what this ISS
because again there's multiple paths to
choose here and so storm simply says his
helmet was at his feet and there was
more than one five helmets I don't know
why there were five the response five
five is the number of magic but it has
other associations The Fifth Sphere is
the sphere of judgment or no mercy is
found there I must ask was this man
truly your friend and storm kind of has
a bit of a recollection right she looks
back on like a lot of the old stories
when it came to Magneto and different
things along those lines where they were
enemies something really important to
point out here specifically to the
history of Magneto this little moment in
the panel where you have him holding
Kitty Pride that was a very very
landmarked story in fact that took place
on Uncanny X-Men issue number 150 that
was the story where with Kitty Pride
being Jewish and Magneto being Jewish
when he attacked her right because she
was trying to stop him from one of his
crazy extremist acts he had realized he
was becoming the very thing that he was
trying to fight against in the sense
that attacking a young Jewish girl he
saw himself while not necessarily
physically but at least philosophically
the same as the Germans from World War
II and so while this did happened during
the events of uncanny Xmen number 150
what you saw was a 50 issue Redemption
Arc that culminated in the iconic
Uncanny X-Men issue number 200 where
Magneto is standing in chains on the
front cover and he's handing himself
over to the world court right atoning
for his past misdeeds that's what
Storm's kind of recollecting on right as
often as she and Magneto were enemies
they were also allies and when it really
came down to it right during the events
of Judgment Day Magneto sacrificed his
life for the mutant population and so
that's where she just kind of Muses to
herself or sort of says he was many
things he has owed many things if he is
suffering I have to try because if this
was just like Magneto from Uncanny X-Men
from like an Uncanny X-Men comic and
like some random month in
1977 then she would have just been like
I mean you know yeah he died man it
happens sometimes I don't know what to
tell you right and she would have just
left him there right that would have
just basically been it but Magneto is
needed because between his leadership
skills and just his raw power this guy
is enough to more than turn the tide
against the fight against orcus right
like the governmental agency just trying
to wipe out mutants on Earth and so
that's where Storm says but now I have a
question that must be answered the
mutant Souls that were here waiting what
became of them and the response would
you wait forever I do not know where
they are I only know which path they
took and they say her road right she
points the finger to basically mistress
death that in effect they passed on to
the true afterlife but that's when the
statements made then they are gone
forever with no hope of return really
more of a question the response there is
always hope they crossed one threshold
already and death is not the barrier
that many believe which again is an
accurate statement we know that from
just a multitude of comics when Jean
Gray as the Phoenix met mistress death
who was actually in Disguise as a
construction worker and explained the
nature of death that at any point in
time a person can be pulled from Death
right we've seen Thanos do that with
people we've seen Thanos banned from the
realm of mistress death right so again
death is not an absolute a person can be
retrieved from there it just depends on
the circumstance but even the statements
made like you can escape this place if
you do not t because what's happening in
the real world is that Ty and Adam
Brasher are trying to resuscitate her
right she's not willing to come back yet
but the fact is Storm says that changes
nothing I came to help my friend and
comrade find the mercy that is being
withheld from him or if he wishes to
bring him back to the fight and if I
must and that's where the statement is
finished for her you'll bring back every
dead Mutant with him oh Oho there are
forces to which even a goddess must bow
specifically addressing the force of the
Living Tribunal now as far as how the
Living Tribunal is involved with the
passing on of the mutant population we
don't necessar necessarily have an
answer to that question but it could be
that the Living Tribunal simply decrees
you have passed on from the living world
there is no coming back for you and
there's nothing storm could do to bring
them back right it would be just a
barrier that she can't cross with no
conceivable way of bringing them back
into the real world and so that's where
kind of recollection comes from asake I
guess we're going to call her that I
don't know exactly how you pronounce her
name but she simply says like what your
dealing with here is a greater conflict
on a greater scale for storm she's
thinking about orcus because storm
doesn't realize the bigger picture she's
not focusing she doesn't know about like
Enigma or the Dominion and all that kind
of stuff she's casually aware of it but
she doesn't understand how deep it goes
but that's the point that asaki is
making here is like there's a much
bigger Conflict at play a much grander
Conflict at Play Magneto holds the key
you will need him and so what she tells
storm is that Magneto entered into that
Tower he went that way now the faith
that awaits him we do not know but you
must follow the path and wind storm does
she falls down through the tower and
comes directly in contact with the
Dominion now the cool thing here is that
the Dominion this is really going to be
clarified in a pretty phenomenal way but
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with that right we did make a video that
specifically addressed this but the long
and short of this is that the the
Dominion themselves can best be
represented as like galatis right so
Galactus travels around he consumes
worlds to satiate his own energy right
and he sends the Silver Surfer out in
order to find worlds that he can consume
now with that example in mind the
Dominion are the result of any kind of
artificial technological advancement
reaching an apex which is to say it just
crosses a threshold right it just learns
so much information that it then
transcends beyond the universe itself
and travels into a space beyond the
universe but there is always a desire to
learn knowledge and so what the
dominions do is they send out emissaries
that's the failing so the failings kind
of play the world of Silver Surfer in
this example the failinks travel through
a universe looking for worlds that have
reached a level of technological
advancement that's basically worth the
time of a dominion and when that happens
those worlds will be brought into the
fold quote unquote by the failinks and
will be handed over to Dominion which
will absorb all that knowledge and then
become more powerful now the cool thing
here is the dominions literally say
greeting acknowledgement warning now the
reason why you see it written this way
this has been a thing ever since
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic 4 and the
way the celestials from the alternate
reality communicated it's a method of
communication that's established by
beings that are trying to communicate
with humans but are not humans usually
technologically advanced in some
capacity so just something to be aware
of here but they say from matter is
energy made from life is information
made life ends information is forever we
are forever outside ever Beyond ever we
are Dominion you are linear we are not
you are single-minded morsal atom
communion error not big enough more
information density required for
resource growth into consumable so ask
the whole thing behind this is that
what's happening is they think storm
just doesn't really have enough
information to matter to them right like
it'd be like Galactus consuming Pluto as
opposed to consuming like Earth right I
mean it might hide him over but it's not
enough to really satisfy him and so
that's why they tell her ask questions
because depending on the kind of
questions she asks they'll gain a better
understanding of how much knowledge she
has and if she has a vast amount of
knowledge or knowledge that's worth
their time they'll consume her like if
Reed Richards SP through this place they
would consume him in an instant they
would be like this guy knows everything
about everything cool let's eat him
right and that would be it they would
absorb his knowledge into themselves so
storm asked the question where am I now
one of the things that I want you guys
to know this will invoke the beyonders
they will be brought up here because
what the Dominion says is beyond outside
mystery Subs sector designated over
space basically they're beyond all space
and time outside of all existence now
they also say meeting space for Cosmic
intellects higher thought forms
accessible via Singularity negative
Singularity Negative Zone origin Point
Multiverse five Cosmos stage six Now The
Junction to everywhere so this is one of
those things where it's kind of
ambiguous because spaces beyond the
Multiverse in Marvel Comics are
represented in different ways there's
the farshore there is just simply this
vast white space where the cosmic
entities meet specifically where they
met during the events of infinity war
after Infinity Gauntlet was over when
Adam Warlock had The Infinity Gauntlet
and was put on trial by The Cosmic
entities before the Living Tribunal it's
all those kinds of things right all
those different spaces but different
writers will depict it in different ways
if I were a betting man I would argue
this is beyond the far Shore right this
is just way way out there in a space
that just hasn't truly been explored
before and so storm Muses to herself and
she asks Dominion Adam mentioned one of
those are there others like you the
response this is where the beyonders get
invoked but this is also where Enigma
comes into play right they say various
exist work consume grow as dominions
exist work consume and grow basically
there are a multitude of us all doing
the exact same thing one threatens
infinite power human level thought
threat potential infinite threat
duration forever omegas beyonders were
are afraid they are linear we are not
containment attempted multiversal reboot
attempted not enough so in effect what
these guys are saying here because they
are referencing Secret Wars from 2015 if
you haven't picked up on that already
right the difference between any of the
dominions that are out there and Enigma
or the Enigma Dominion represented in
the X-Men Comics is that these Enigma
are just the result of artificial
intelligence right but artificial
intelligence at least in its current
form does not think the way a human does
right human thought potential is
Limitless and so Enigma unlike these
thinks like a human it's like if a human
had gained or had Blended itself with
technology and then achieved a vast
level of power it's beyond anything out
there and that's why they say the Enigma
threatens everything it threatens all
known Cosmic entities in a lot of ways
depending on how you want to look at it
you could see the Enigma is even being
like Marvel writers or Marvel editors
not in the sense that they threaten
everything but the amount of power they
have over everything they can just edit
whatever they want to change whatever
they want to and it becomes absolute
specifically and this is something that
we already knew about from Defenders
beyond that the Enigma Dominion being
out there had been known for quite some
time we had only just realized it that
the real motivation behind the beyonders
initiating Secret Wars as much as I
don't like the change in motivation is
that they were looking for a way to
basically blink out the Multiverse in
order to give the Enigma no reason to
come here and then in turn they could
bring it back once the Dominion had
basically just moved on right and so it
would be unaware that the Multiverse had
returned and it would just kind of go
and do its thing and that would
basically be it such as it was the
superheroes fought for the return of the
Multiverse not truly understanding the
motivation of the beyonders which makes
sense because they never explained
themselves right they were just like we
are from Beyond and we're just going to
wipe everything out and Dr Doom like no
you're not either he unleashes the
molecule men and the molecule men blow
up and destroy all the beyonders and
then Dr Doom basically seizes their
power and then you get secret Wars 2015
so it's one of those things where
because of that right like a lot of this
is kind of mysterious and even storm
says I can feel the danger in this place
these intelligences hunger in some
Eternal way that I cannot fathom and
each new drop of knowledge makes me a
sweeter meal so be it ask your third
question auro make your third wish wish
and pray the Genies Grant it without
asking their price and so she says I am
seeking the soul of a man Max eisenhart
Magneto and they say we know who he is
we are aware of him right a rare Adam we
looked at him paired his to the base
strata cataloged his pain studied him
then sent him on not viable useful
enough information for assimilation
consumption but information of Interest
right so he was he didn't know enough
for us to absorb him into ourselves but
you do storm so like literally they try
to eat
her they try to consume her now at that
moment storm basically attacks them just
long enough to effectively make her
escape and when that happens she just
kind of comes falling down into the same
location Magneto was in surrounded by
these almost kind of helmets for herself
not really helmets but like the little
you know tias if we want to call it that
whatever you want to call it right but
she's surrounded by these things and
she's like where wherever it is that
Magneto is at and whatever he's dealing
with it is an effect his own personal
hell so I have to go and find him rescue
him from it and bring him back but with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end massive Cliffhanger
but uh if you guys need to get caught up
on the X-Men make sure you guys click
the playlist which will get you filled
in and it'll answer any questions you
have and I will catch you all later
peace